your pattern is scored based on the number 10 so out of 10 is your mark
as you can see it's split up into two parts we have our accuracy and our presentation on this
side so we'll start off with the accuracy first so your accuracy is actually scored from a four
so from the number four you're actually marked during your presentation of your pattern
and then with that one any mistakes that you make whether if it's a minor mistake get a minus
of a 0.1 if it's a major mistake you get minus 0.3 so i'll just let you guys know about the
difference between the two so with a minor mistake it's a very very small thing so say
we're doing a outer block if it's not your shoulder height maybe it's a little bit lower
or maybe it's a tiny bit higher that's a minor mistake so that's a zero point
one a major mistake would be you're supposed to do an outer block in the pattern but you forget
and you say you do a rich hand strike instead so that would be a major mistake so with the
minor mistake let's say pattern one for example there's 20 steps it's not uncommon to have up to
maybe 14 15 mistakes in the 20 patterns sorry the 20 steps so the reason for that one being
it needs to be absolutely perfect to get
uh to not get a deduction of 0.1 so it's not uncommon let's say there's 20 steps and you made
let's say 15 mistakes so what would that be so we'll leave that there on this side and we'll
come back and we'll just calculate the square at the end so a major mistake say you're supposed to
turn to the left when you turn to the right that would be a major mistake so obviously we do want
to try to avoid any of these major mistakes
okay so uh after we've done our pattern that's when we move on to the presentation side so the
presentation as you can see it's from a score of six uh this six is actually split up into three
parts so we have one two three here so with this one uh for a score of two is your power and speed
your rhythm is also a score of two and your expression of energy is also scored out of two
as well so we'll start off with the power and speed so with this one we're going to start with
whether it's your blocks, your kicks, your strikes, your punches, anything that you do,
you need to be nice and strong, and it has to be fast as well.
So it's one thing to have a very strong punch, or a very fast punch,
but it has to be both strong and fast to get high in that category.
The next part is your rhythm.
So the rhythm, when you do start your pattern, there is a rhythm to the pattern.
It's not just really fast all the way through, it's not slow all the way through,
there's a slow, fast, slow, fast kind of aspect to it as well.
So you do need to kind of work on your rhythm, and that's also scored out of two.
The last bit is your expression of energy.
So what is expression of energy?
So that's basically how loud you shout, so how much intensity you have during your pattern as well.
So say you're doing your pattern really well, it's really fast and it's strong,
your rhythm is really great, but you're not shouting very loud,
or you can kind of tell.
The judges can kind of tell you're not really confident, you're a little bit nervous,
so that's what we need to kind of improve on as well.
So I'll just come around to this side.
So with this one, for color belts and black belts, it's actually scored a little bit differently.
So if you're a color belt, you'll actually, your average, so where the judges actually mark you from,
it's actually from a 1.1.
So this is your average.
So,
say you did, you did alright, you did average compared to everyone else,
your score for 1, 2, and 3, it'll start from a 1.1.
So if you're less than average in the judges' eyes, you might go down to, say for your power and speed,
you might get a 1 or even a 0.9.
If you did really great, you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4.
So each individual category, you need to obviously get as high as you can.
If you're a black belt,
generally, depending on the competition, you will be scored from a 1.3.
So 1.3 would be your average that you start from.
So say your power and speed was above average, you might get scored a 1 point, say, let's say 1.4 for now.
Say your rhythm was only about average.
It wasn't amazing.
It might be just a 1.3, but let's say you didn't shout very loud.
So your expression,
your kind of energy, your average was 1.3, it might drop to, say, let's say a 1.0.
So with this one, we'll come over down to this side.
So with this one, as I was saying, it's a total of 10.
So let's see.
And for presentation, we had 0.7, 1, 2, 3.
So you had a 3.7.
Let's say you made 15 mistakes.
So with this one, obviously, don't be too discouraged if you do get pretty high in your mistakes.
This is with the judges.
We have three judges usually at the panel and each judge, obviously, it's very subjective.
So from their point of view, you might have made a lot of mistakes or you may have made not a lot of mistakes as well.
So that's why we have the three judges and we average it out as well.
Okay, so say we did now.
15 mistakes, very small mistakes.
So if they're all minus 0.1, it'd be 1.5.
So you go 4.0 minus 1.5, which equals 2.5.
So this would be your accuracy score.
So with our presentation like before, we're saying we got a 3.7 here.
So we add these numbers after the judges are finished scoring.
So we get a pattern, a 6.2, which is actually very good.
So I'll just talk about a little bit more now about this number here.
So if you're a color belt, if you're a yellow or above and you do your patterns, it's not uncommon.
Generally, for a color belt, the average is about a 4 to 5.
So if you get a number between 4 and 5 out of 10 for your pattern,
that's actually generally considered pretty good.
So anything above that, you can consider yourself pretty good.
If you're a black belt, the average would say,
because we're talking here about the higher presentation as an average,
anything from 5 to 6 is actually considered pretty good.
And anything over a 7 is actually considered almost world-class.
So if you get a 7 for any of your patterns,
you generally need to pat yourself on the back because you did an amazing job.
So we just went through our Punze scoring.
So just remember, accuracy is a 4.0.
Presentation is a 6.0.
Accuracy is judged during your pattern.
Presentation is after.
And then we get the two scores that we add up and we get that number.
So with this one, obviously,
I was judge number one.
I would give you a 6.2.
There was another judge on the other side.
Maybe he saw a couple more mistakes than I did.
So maybe this one would be a little bit lower.
It might be a 5 point something.
Another judge on the other side,
they scored a little bit higher.
So we'd get the three numbers and then we'd average that as well.
So I hope this helped you guys.
So make sure you enjoy your Punze competitions.
And make sure, obviously,
you record down your numbers as well.
So it's very important.
So both the plus and the minus count the errors?
Yes.
So minor errors and major errors.
So real time, you can rate yourself.
We cannot boss this time just like the real judges.
So while you're watching major error,
you can go up.
Minor and then after the performance,
you would rate your power and speed,
coordination, rhythm, and the expression of energy.
Continue.
Okay.
When you're ready.
Thank you.